ويليام بوي معلم الفرنسيه شاب يعيش ويعمل
في السعوديه لفت الانظار على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وليم نشر سلسله المقاطع
الفيديو التي يظهر فيها بالزي السعودي
التقليدي ويتحدث العربيه بطلاقه ويلتزم
بالعادات والتقاليد في محادثاته مدرس
اللغه الفرنسيه المقيم في الرياض قدم
رؤيته الخاصه للسعوديه التي اعجب بتفاصيل
الحياه فيها وبالعادات والتقاليد واستطاع
الاندماج مع السعوديين وتكوين صدقات كبيره
معهم من مختلف المناطق وليام احب السعوديه
بعد زيارته الاولى للحج اعجبه حينها
باللغه العربيه وقرر ان يدرسها في الجامعه
بفرنسا ثم بدا في كتابه روايه باللغه
العربيه
لكنه ذهب الى ابعد من ذلك بكثير على ما
يبدو
الحين انا اشرب الشاي في المتحف النائف في
المدينه الجبه ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
المتحف رائع جدا جدا
نستمتع بالهدوء السحره
اليوم الوطني
ينضم الينا من الرياض الاستاذ الفرنسي
وليام بوي ويليام اهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه شكرا على تواجدك معانا
نعم نعم
تقولون اشعر بالانتماء للسعوديه او حب
الحياه فيها والتعامل مع اهلها هل لك ان
تحكي لنا كيف بدات قصتك مع السعوديه
واليوم
قصتي بدات في طريق الحج عن الان دخلت في
الاسلام وذهبت الى الحج لما كنت تمانيه
عشر من عمري واكتشفت السعوديه بتاريخ الحج
الناس في هذا الزمان كنت لا انا كنت لا
تتحدث اللغه العربيه
والتقيت بالسعوديين وكنت اريد ان اتحدث
معهم ولكن لا استمتاع هذا السبب رجعت
علامه اللغه العربيه
وحصلته على الماجستير واا عدت الى
السعوديه همم خاصه في الرياض ليمارس اللغه
العربيه واا نعم واليام ما هذا لغتك
العربيه ممتازه يعني تكاد تكون افضل من
العرب انفسهام على كل حال اليوم عيون
السياح لها نظره مختلفه عن عيون اهل البلد
لتفاصيله فما ابرز مالفتك في السعوديه
كفرنسي قادم الى السعوديه اولا
اه السعوديه
هي بره الرحمن هي بلد السعاده هي بلاد
الامان وانا انصح الفرنسيه
والشعب السعوديه اللطيفه جدا
اقول السلام عليكم واهلا وسهلا الى شخص
سعودي
[موسيقى]
ولا تتحدثها بطلاقه فقط ولكن تحرس على
الالتزام بالتقاليد السعوديه والعدد
السعوديه وحتى الظهور مش زي التقليدي كمان
نشاهدك اليوم ونشاهدك على مواقع التواصل
من خلال فيديوهاتك ليش تح ازايك
طيب انا انا اعتقد السعوديه يجوز الهويه
انا فرنسي اصلي من كل اجدادي 100% ولكن
انا اتحدث اللغه العربيه لانني احب
السعوديه عشان اكتشفت اهل السعوديه في
السعوديه والحين انا ادرس اللغه الفرنسيه
الى الطلاب السعوديين وانا فخور فخوره جدا
انا عندي الاخلاص مثلا عندما البس الزي
السعودي انا انا اعتبره ذلك كما اخلاص
الاخلاص في الكلام وقوه الكلام
وهذا الشباب انا فخور مثلا الاقل تمثال
الفقر فخر العرب وهذه السبب انا فخوره جدا
ويشرفني كثيرا مثلا عندما اراء السعوديين
يلبسوا البداله الفرنسيه في فرنسا
وانا اريد السعوديون لديهم نفس السعاده
ونفس الشرف عندما يراني بالزي السعودي
وانت يعني لا تلبس فقط الزي السعودي وايضا
تاكل الاكل السعودي وراينا الصور بالكبسه
السعوديه كلها على الطريقه الاصليه بس
بصراحه يعني ايهما افضل الاكل السعودي ولا
الاكل الفرنسي اوه سؤال صعب هذا الشيء
تختلط تماما لا تستطيع ان نفعل المقرره
مثلا همم في في فرنسا الجمال فرنسا
انا احبك كثير كثير من زمان
2015 هذا السعوديه طيب غير زي التقليدي
وغير ال- همم التقاليد السعوديه والاكل
السعودي سمعته وخبرتني العصفوره انك تحب
وتسمع اغاني محمد عبده اغاني سعوديه
نعم انا انا كله كل شيء سعودي انا احبك
كثيرا ومحمد عبده ومثلا العباره بمجستش ما
قصرت الحين ما قصرت انت بتحب عباره ما
قصرت في عبارات ثانيه كمان يا ويليام هيك
تحكيلنا اياها كلمات سعوديه بحته
كلمه اخرى ممكن كفو كفو عليك
سمعنا اغنيه يا ويليام هيك على
محمد عبده
ههه
انا احب السعوديه واعلى الفكره ان نصراويه
هذه السباق
ههه وكيف رايك بكريستيانو رونالدو
انا سعيد جدا اخبارك
كريستيانو 2017
طيب وليم انت كيف تفاعل السعوديين مع
اللغه الفرنسيه بحكم انك استاذ فرنسي
ين في اهتمام باللغه الفرنسيه لاحظت يعني
من خلال تدريسك للغه الفرنسيه عم
بتستفيدوا من خبرات بعض
ايوه انا كنت اريد ان اكون مستفيد للشعب
السعودي
في تعليم اللغه الفرنسيه والحين انا اشرح
القواعد يعني القواعد الفرنسيه مع الاعراب
همم العربيه يعني المقرر الاول انتم اللاب
يحب طريقه التعلم
يفهمون الحمد لله ساعه جدا جدا
يعيش في السعوديه ويتحدث اللغه العربيه
شكرا لك ميرسي